he's calling his 23rd NBA all-star game
this Sunday on TNT he is than one in the
only Marv Albert how are you Marv hey 23
all-star games unbelievable
what was your first can you recall that
well uh it was actually the first was on
radio at Madison Square Garden I don't
remember that much about honest but I do
remember last years and we hope it does
not go the same way and I think they've
come up with a couple of wrinkles that
will affect the 190 to 182 final
optional and you know they were more
inclined Davis of the pelicans because
the game was in New Orleans but it's a
celebration of basketball as you know
it's a fun weekend and the game is
usually schoolyard until the third or
fourth quarter but this one went the
distance in that matter so I think
they've come up with a few things that
will change it and you know should be
should be much better the one thing I
must say that about NBA also against the
players even if they're injured you know
love to show up just for the
introductions and and it's not
necessarily true in other sports where
you have all-star games I mean guys look
you know to take time off and I know it
has a lot to do with their quote brands
and you know appearances and all that
weekend but still you know the guys
really players wants to take part so
Marvin I'm you know I know you say in
terms of your first these there is there
one all-star game moment that you think
stands out amongst others that you can
you know entertain us with a story on
that front actually a couple the first
one that comes to mind was it was 1997
in Cleveland they had the 50 greatest
players of all time honored and you know
just to see that group there was
incredible but in the game Glen Rice
was on his way to setting at all-star
record for most points in a quarter
which would break will Chamberlain's
record and the OP or the kind of amusing
thing to me was wilt was sitting
courtside and was really annoyed you can
tell that he was vociferously rooting
against web mice who did set it he had
20 points in this in the third quarter
and and so even overshadow there was a
triple-double by Michael Jordan
that game rarely sees little devils in
an all-star game
so that was I I think the most memorable
and then there was one really good
all-star game in recent years it was
early 2000s the East won by one point is
111 110 and they came back from a
21-point deficit and the fourth quarter
was a it was a duel and it was Allen
Iverson
Stephon Marbury who had a shootout with
Kobe Bryant and that was that was
thrilling to do Marv Albert it was
really a good game Marv Albert here on
the Rich Eisen show calling in from here
in Los Angeles hey Marv I don't know if
you're on a landline or not but it's
very difficult to understand you it's
it's interfering with the rim right now
in terms of popularity and Jordan being
being towards the top is there any and
anybody else that you think right now
that is compared with the because this
is sort of a popularity contest here
Marv right but you know I think there
are more stars now then in Michaels days
I think people are anxious to see James
Hart Russell Westbrook Durant a better
combo who it's funny
he opened the game last season playing
so hard and guys are looking at you know
what are you doing and then he realized
that you know that they're not you know
no one wants to get injured but he is so
exciting
he's one of the guys we'll be hearing it
from the crowd of course LeBron too you
know but and Steph Curry there there are
so many stars now in the league and what
is appealing is as opposed to other
sports and it is so recognizable you
know so I think that that makes a
difference and I think particularly
early there will be guys who will go
schoolyard and you know hopefully we get
a game come late third early fourth best
schoolyard player you've ever seen is
who Marvin
actually in the schoolyard not like
Julio down by the schoolyard schoolyard
type player that you have son who would
be would be G would be curry harden
mostly off the dribble guys Westbrook
what about and Durant seeing a guy like
that who you know is he's listed at 611
seven-foot he probably is really 7 1 7
to lose that handle the ball so well and
also play at the other end defensively
he can he's become a very good defender
and LeBron you know LeBron to would be
unstoppable in that you know and that
kind of flow of a game
what about all-time all-time well
they're guys you go back you know there
are people like tiny Archibald Pistol
Pete Maravich Marbury to in his day
mm-hmm
I would but I put some of the current
guys Kyrie Irving also had and harden
and curry I've never seen anyone like
curry who gets the shot off I guess in
in less than a second you know he can
just catch and shoot and the way he
handles the ball I mean it's it's almost
like it's ballet the way his foot
and the same with hard snow step back he
I mean he Hardin is not fast but he has
he's so deceptive in terms of his moves
and he finds space I've never seen
anybody quite like that I mean you know
the game is is a different level looks
like even if you see kids played today
because they're so affected by what what
they're watching and I mean the free
point shot has had a great influence on
kids which is you know can be good and
bad I mean it definitely you see young
young players you know heaving up shots
from all angles but they're just doing
what they see guys like curry and harden
who are so good at it and you know I
mean curry could hit from the center
court and it's not you know looks like a
casual shot so before we let you go Marv
Albert the poll question today Chris
Brockman would you please mind go for it
hey Marv what's the greatest NBA
all-star weekend moment so we narrowed
it down to four MJ from the foul line in
1988 Larry Bird's the legendary
three-point win where he wagged the
finger Magic Johnson's 92 MVP
performance or Vince Carter's a
legendary dunk contest performance
that's a tough question but I happened
to call this Carter won I had never seen
you know they talked about the triple
axel in the Olympics and I'd never seen
anything like that bird the bird one was
really amusing and he claimed he just
constituted offhandedly you know just to
bother guys and was telling them prior
to the contest you know there's no
reason for you to show up but the Carter
and everybody knowing at the time the
judges it was over and I remember Kenny
Smith was doing it with me and he's
screaming it's all over but that that
probably would be the which is obviously
not in the game but that probably would
be the moment that stands out the most
amazing all right
well are you calling me slam dunk as
well this time around or not resting up
during the slam dunk a little I always
promised my wife that we will sit in the
stands and watch it I really enjoy the
Saturday I'm just sitting there and you
know watching all the stuff slam dunk
this year is going to be really terrific
well there's only four in it I mean I
probably makes it better that way
why is that you don't have Robinson you
know going for 30 minutes on continually
trying not to have limit to the rules a
little bit so III think that's good
because I think all four guys are will
be outstanding well I'll be in the
stands too with uh with my wife and kids
and hopefully we'll get to to meet
because I I would love that it would be
a thrill for my kids to meet you Murph
that would be awesome as you know and
and I assume you're a sit down guy right
you don't stand up and you know front of
yes Daddy so you have to you don't tell
them please would you mind sit down you
don't do that you're not that guy no I I
have Micro telecoms with me he like
shoves them away barb take care we'll
chat soon
thanks again thank you as always it's
Marvel the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience